Mariya doh that's not her real name is a
comedian here's her picture never seen
her before right she just went to court
to change that there she filed a
restraining order was it against the
violent stalker or an unstable ex no it
was against Donald Trump she cited
anxiety over his comments on nuclear war
so she went to court waited in line
filled out paperwork but sadly she was
denied now you can call this performance
art or self-promotion
I call it clueless she's doing this as
we just dropped missiles on Syria for
using chemical weapons on kids
so her actions actually ignore Trump's
real response to actual suffering as
opposed to what's going on in her head
she's also not up to date on world
events the risk for nuclear war is
actually shrinking North and South Korea
are now planning serious talks who
spurred that more important chances are
we all know women mom's sisters
co-workers faced with threats who have
had to file restraining orders it's not
comedy it's terror that Maria was in a
government office wasting valuable time
perhaps while other women were waiting
to get real restraining orders against
real threats makes this joke less funny
I doubt the women there had the time for
clever PR stunts but because Maria is
cool and hates Trump she'll be cheered
by her peers not so much by real victims
seeking real protection but what do they
know about comedy so I think Dana she's
since backed up I didn't mention her
name because I thought that would feed
into the PR thing and I figure don't
give it to her idea not giving these
people attention exactly but I think she
might have worked you think this if you
do it look if you're gonna do a stunt
don't do it at other peoples expense
right you know she's well known for her
jokes about depression and anxiety
that's not very funny it is to me but
yours is amazing on a plane not let's
not bring up planes yes yes anyway I
don't think she's up on current events
Jesse Greg I think you just totally got
hosed by this person yeah she wanted to
do this stunt yes she's the subject of a
gutfeld monologue but she won but
there's no names what's going on here
and she's got a huge promotional plug
and then your school arming her about
gumming up the works at the courts you
know you don't think that's I think
that's really bad it's not like she
called 911
wait waiting in line while somebody else
is behind you to do a stunt
okay Kimberly you're a prosecutor you
deal with restraining orders you think
it's funny to use a restraining order no
as a political show because they're
people that really need that that's my
victims okay it's they're very serious
cases out there where they're utilized
to protect public safety and an
individual safety perhaps from someone
who would want to do them harm or kill
them that being the case you still did
this yeah yeah cuz you were pop you
believed in it and Jesse threw shade at
you yeah I did the restraining order
against Obama I would have had him on my
show at least you were the wacky world
all right whoa tional II traumatized
wait that's the name of that comedian
that was holding his head that woman
comedian so she's back never I know and
I I don't know maybe it's kind of
desperat me on the other hand I'm not
gonna ever make fun of somebody
suffering from depression but I do think
but she says it made her more anxious
Kimberly because of Trump's language
about my big button and all that
I don't know oh my god she should watch
the South Park episode about this it'll
cheer her up it'll be just fine it's
just so-now are aren't the north and
south coming together yeah yes what's
you so anxious you gotta go all right